I want to will ask you his first
question by using a quote from Seawright
Mills in his book power elite or some
other book he said if you if somebody
starts talking about power and the use
of power you're automatically a
muckraker right power is a word that
Americans are just very uncomfortable
with we're willing to talk about
influence and what we basically like to
believe is that individuals and groups
can join together to influence specific
issues but power is something that
happens in Europe it's it's part of the
whole American experience to put no
emphasis upon the idea of social class
and to put no emphases on the idea of
power why do you think this is I think
that it comes out of out of the classic
liberal tradition and out of American
history of rebelling against the the
king and in the American Revolution but
and then from there I think it's because
the American experience has been
seemingly very individualistic that is
people have moved across the country
there are is evidence of upward mobility
people have become wealthy they have
been able to get education and change
their station in life a little bit and I
think that then reinforces this kind of
belief so that the idea that there is a
power structure in a social structure is
then something that that we want to
ignore now I must say that we know it we
know that there's the other side of the
tracks and there's the people that live
in the nice houses we have all of these
euphemisms that we use for power
structures and for social classes this
what is the dominant view in the
universities of the United States of
what you call the power structure I
think the dominant view in in the
university is something we call
pluralism which says that influence the
United States is exercised by specific
individuals who come together as a
coalition or an interest group to work
on one particular kind of issue so we
always stay
the level of individuals and groups and
we never talk in terms of long-standing
institutional structures which sounds
pretty abstract but that gets down to
things like corporations or foundations
that for 60 or 80 years have been giving
out great amount of money to to
influence directions that policy take I
think that whole that whole kind of
level drops out of our thinking and I
think that our educational system does
reinforce that and what led you to take
his different approach to power why did
you become dissatisfied with the
pluralist approach and start looking at
the power structure in different terms I
think that for me it was probably
because of many of the events of the
1960s when people tried to exercise
their rights such as in the civil rights
movement or such as in the anti-war
movement of the time or even in some of
the attempts by consumer advocates such
as Ralph Nader basically when when they
seem to be meeting a stone wall then you
kind of think there may be something
else more there I like but Ralph Nader
said in regard to in regard to your
question that he says said is that if
you want to find out about the power
structure you got to go out there and
kind of bump up against it the way you
find is there is when you hit these
brick walls and as I saw that happening
I got more interested in trying to see
if there was this class and
institutional structure and basically I
started out in a I think a good old
American way by trying to trace
individuals in their in their in their
activities and what I found standing
behind these individuals I believe our
Lord large corporations large
foundations a series of research
institutes a series of policy discussion
groups that make it so that a David
Rockefeller is not merely an individual
but is in fact constantly involved
whether it's with a bank or his
foundation or policy discussion group
like the Council on Foreign Relations
and then one begins to see that there's
an ongoing in
to tional structure and so that even
then when David Rockefeller retires you
see that the people that now run Jace
Manhattan Bank that now are the
directors of the Council on Foreign
Relations continue to be the people that
run the country so that when you get a
little time perspective on it you start
to see the individuals change a little
bit but that they come from the same
social background and they come from the
same large institutions so I tried them
to find that structure that stood behind
our individual actions well let's take a
look at this and I guess we should start
with the class the class structure and
class nature of the United States now we
hear about middle class very frequently
as written a lot of things are studied
about the middle class and a lot of
things been written about the middle
class
you see frequently lower middle class
and lower but you don't see too much
written about upper class enough there's
a middle class there has to be an upper
right I think they're very definitely is
an upper class in the United States and
indeed that's been the starting point of
my research is to start with social
clubs exclusive private schools summer
resorts to start with what we can see if
we will but look to see these people as
a set of interacting and intermarrying a
set of families who have developed a
whole set of social institutions that
preserve their way of life once we have
located these various schools clubs
resorts retreats debutante balls then we
can understand the historical continuity
of social upper-class in America it's my
belief that about half a percent of
Americans are part of what I would call
a social upper-class and these people
owned about 20 to 25 percent of all the
privately held wealth in the United
States that is if we took all of your
wealth which might be your car your
house your insurance policy if we threw
in your guitar and every
we took all of that wealth plus the
stocks and bonds in real estate in
America would put all that in a big pile
20 to 25% of all of that one half of one
percent of the people have that in the
United States and what my thesis
basically says is that those people that
have that 20 to 25 percent of all the
privately held wealth are not mere
individuals that are scattered here and
there and are kind of rare and don't
know each other but in fact they are are
closely knit they know each other they
see the world the same way they do
discuss with each other are the kinds of
policies that they think would further
their way of life so in that sense we
then talk about them in this more
sociological abstracts sense that
they're not just families because in
fact there there are these ongoing
institutional kinds of structures and
they are structures that do matter and
they make a difference to a lot of
Americans as they attempt to emulate
these people as they attempt to become
part of these institutions and so on now
under this their institutions and their
structures do two things or three they
first they perpetuate themselves they
exclude other people they have
mechanisms to exclude other people from
joining them absolutely and but they
also they use the mechanisms to bring up
new blood when they think these people
have the right credentials and right I
think one of the most dramatic examples
that I know of that Frank concerns the
way in which moderate members of the
upper class responded to the civil
rights movement of the 60s and the
rebellions that were going on in the
inner cities in the ghettos at that time
and that was that a number of these
institutions of which we're talking
decided that they really had to find the
best and the brightest of the black
community and to educate them so they
could be more a part of the corporate
structure and what they simply did was
to get money from the four
and Rockefeller Foundation's and a
couple others and then to go to leading
private schools and say we want to
create a scholarship program for black
students this program is called ABC a
better chance and literally over the
space then of ten or fifteen years many
thousands of young black students were
taken into these prep schools and then
from there went on to major colleges and
universities with fellowships and these
people are now out there in their 30s
being in the media being in the
corporate law working for corporations
we've interviewed some of these people
it's very fascinating the way it shows
you so nicely about class because these
people who gradually take on the style
and manner of the school of which they
were a part and they they tell us it's
very funny that they'll go home and
people say you're starting to talk
different you're and and they say you
know it's I go and I'd like to visit my
family but my other friends I don't have
anything in common with them anymore and
that's what we mean you see by then a
social class you know if one has read
all about American history and knows
about various kinds of arts that most
people don't know about if you've had
European vacations then you want to talk
to other people that can talk your
language and and gradually then these
people come to feel different from the
very group that they originally came
from I use this example because I think
it is so dramatic in the sense that
we're taking very poor people out of out
of a ghetto and taking them to this
private school where they're one of two
or three or four black people at what
age that way Oh fourteen fifteen sixteen
and and making them part of this class
in the sense of putting them there and
then and then they gradually just out of
human processes of while you're at
school you certainly want to relate to
other people you want to get along and
before you know it you're like the
people that that you're going to school
which is socialization and that's right
exactly
enter
marrying with their white social social
upper-class people or do they bring
black women into this there are Emma's
but there are black women in the program
as well and I don't know the answer to
that question in terms of any systematic
data yet we've only interviewed a few of
the people but definitely then there is
some intermarriage I guess the next big
question then there is this upper class
in the United States is it a ruling
class a governing class it is a cohesive
yeah I I believe that first it is
cohesive and and secondly that it is a
ruling class I think that we see the
cohesion in the fact that these people
are members of each other's clubs so to
speak that is if we look at club
memberships all over the United States
we would find that a leading banker in
New York may well be in clubs in Los
Angeles and in San Francisco we find in
the case of a club I've studied with
some care called the Bohemian Club in
San Francisco that people from all of
the United States come to its two-week
retreat in the last part of July and
sleep together in tents and huts and
teepees and just kind of go to summer
camp together they literally do go to
summer camp together there's a lot of
that kind of social cohesiveness
there's also cohesiveness in the
corporate world and that they sit on
each other's corporate boards so that
the head of Chase Manhattan Bank such as
David Rockefeller until recent years
will sit on two or three other
corporation boards but the head of those
corporations will also sit on the board
of Chase Manhattan Bank so they take it
each other's laundry at the economic
level as well they also come together to
talk about more general issues whether
it's foreign policy or kinds of domestic
policy at what I call discussion groups
but this means organizations like the
Committee for Economic Development
the Council on Foreign Relations the
conference board the Business Council
there's numerous of these groups so I
think there is cohesiveness in this
group as a social class and as and in
terms of its economic interest
we've been talking a lot or referring to
the Council on Foreign Relations
Committee for Economic Development
trilateral commission let's talk in
greater detail about the policy planning
mechanisms some of these organizations
that we've been talking about because I
think this is probably the thing that
people know least about you don't find
him in history books and you don't fight
him in economics textbooks and all tell
us about these basically these were
organizations were all created at
different times in the 20th century in
the face of particular problems that
were faced by the corporate community in
the case of the Council on Foreign
Relations
it was formed shortly after World War 1
when States people came in corporate
leaders came back from their side and
they said we have to have a better
perspective on Foreign Relations now
that we're clearly going to be the
dominant power in the world and they
created this discussion group in order
to make themselves more sophisticated
about these issues these these
organizations are funded by large
corporations and by foundations they
then bring together these business
people for discussions with academic
experts these academic experts are
basically housed at Institute's on major
campuses the Harvard Yale Princeton
Columbia Stanford Johns Hopkins Berkeley
MIT Caltech Nexus and these experts are
also housed at think tanks like the RAND
Corporation and various institutes for
strategic thinking here there and
everywhere so what we have at a policy
discussion group is the bringing
together of a variety of academic
opinions with this range of corporate
leaders and they then discuss a
particular issue as I say a foreign
policy issue a monetary policy issue a
particular domestic issue and they try
to work out ideas that make sense to all
of them now from the corporate point of
view by listening say they got a liberal
academic and a more conservative
academic in the same room and they
listen to you guys argue and then they
see what makes sense in terms of their
view of the world and interest you can
right so I might then so then in that
situation now beyond them becoming
sophisticated about policies they also
you see are looking at each other in
terms of who can do this more general
kind of tasks meaning this and I think
we've all seen in our lives we have
friends that might be very good at their
particular job they might be very good
say it running a business but if you ask
them to do a more general thing like
beyond the City Council they maybe don't
do very well because they don't relate
well to other groups we see this with
faculty people people that do a fine job
in their department but maybe they would
you wouldn't want them on a general
committee of the faculty because they
they're impatient with student demands
or they get angry with the
administration so we say we don't want
to put that person on that committee so
what they do is informally learn about
each other's leadership capability but
what I that's one thing that's learned
that these organizations but the other
thing that's learned is which academic
expert makes sense to me and can I
personally relate to so it's at these
organizations that you meet somebody
like a Henry Kissinger and you say he
not only makes sense but I get along
with him personally so you develop then
this relationship between the corporate
community and the expert community at
these organizations so they are a place
where these people get a more general
view where they get sophisticated where
they informally select each other's
leaders where they inject academic
opinion into their into their
perspectives where they look academic
experts over to become potential
advisors in the government and then and
very importantly what these
organizations do is they legitimate
these people as fair-minded expert you
see the interesting thing about politics
in America in terms of policies as
opposed to electing individuals is that
the political organizations of the
ruling class are not called political
know that see that's an irony yeah in a
way that is all the groups in America
that are called nonpartisan bipartisan
non-political that's the political
organizations of the ruling class in
America you see if you go out and say I
don't understand how you
a ruling class there's a Democrats over
here there's a Republicans over here
that's politics isn't it no that's just
deciding which individuals will fill
offices politics in the important sense
of which policies we all agree are makes
sense that happens in non political
organization so when the committee for
Economic Development puts out a
statement it says the committee for
Economic Development a nonpartisan group
of business people today suggested we
alter the Social Security system in the
following way and then they say look
some of our members are Democrats some
of our members are Republicans we're
trying to get something that's good for
all of America we're trying to transcend
politics we're trying to do something
that's that's in the national interest
now once you say yeah that's fair we got
to get beyond this fight between
Republicans and Democrats they're there
they're people that have they can run an
organization their success in America
and then we identify with them because
of their high status and because they're
part of this fair-minded organization
academic experts from Harvard have
helped them and from Yale and who are we
you know
argue with somebody from Harvard and
Yale plus a successful business leader
and that's what we call legitimation in
my mind of their policy and we respect
them I know that because I go around and
talk about these things or debate these
things and so many times people will
stand up average I'll say hey who why
shouldn't the man from General Motors
run the country he's a winner he shone
like Iacocca they're talking about
Iacocca should be president right look
at him he's a wonderful guy he's proven
it he's run these corporations what do
you want for nothing others that that
has made him somebody that Americans
will will accept and relate to and
they'll go along with those policies so
that's the role then to come back to
these organizations that they play this
kind of legitimation of policies that
are in the general interest the ruling
class and are labeled nonpartisan and
then these policies not only are put
into effect but also the people from
these organizations are placed in
positions of decision-making power in
the government right
and I think that the policies
incidentally to be a little academic
about it I think that the policies could
be implemented without necessarily
putting the people in government but
it's the fact that the people that go in
to go into government that's what we can
see most clearly and that's what people
can kind of can kind of relate to or
identify with they can see what you're
talking about if you show the movement
of Donald Regan from Merrill Lynch to
the Business Roundtable to government
and then if you say the same thing
happens under Democrats or if you show
the movement of Henry Kissinger from
Harvard to the Council on Foreign
Relations to the paid staff of Nelson
Rockefeller and then finally to the
government with under Nixon then we can
see that the what's happening it might
be that a lot of times that important
policies come out of these organizations
without necessarily the particular
person coming to government exactly
where to put this then at the level of
persons again from the point of view of
these academic experts what they're
trying to do is to attach themselves to
somebody that they think is going to be
successful because the culmination of an
academic experts career is to be a Henry
Kissinger and when I say that I'm
thinking of Brzezinski paczynski was
always sort of in the shadow of
Kissinger but he was always in these
discussion groups I'm talking about he
headed an important think-tank at
Columbia and he was always in Council on
Foreign Relations Study Group well David
Rockefeller asked presence key to head
up the staff for this organization
called the trilateral commission which
is a discussion group of prominent
leaders from the Western European
nations plus Japan plus the United
States
incidentally they're all people all
these countries have a Council on
Foreign Relations and they're basically
people from the National Council on
Foreign Relations David Rockefeller
asked Burzynski to head this the staff
for this this new discussion group that
started in the 70s and when the man from
coca-cola suggested to David Rockefeller
Jimmy Carter be a part of that group
Brzezinski met Carter at the track
counsel at the trilateral commission now
from Brazil sqeeze point of view
he looked and he said this guy might
make it the president I'm going to bet
on him in effect and the result will be
I get to be a national security adviser
someday so there is that whole
subjective part of what the academic is
doing there in terms of this is a guy I
can relate to and I think he's going to
be a winner so we could I could explain
all of what I've been talking about from
a subjective careerist point of view for
an individual like a Kissinger or a
Brzezinski but my point is is he a lot
of a bet on the wrong guy that is they
decided they were going to work for
George Romney well who remembers George
Romney you know or they decided they're
going to work for some particular
Democrat that that lost out somewhere
made a fatal faux pas and so we don't
hear of them but they probably maybe has
an important policy inputs but they
themselves did not arrive in the
government because they bet on the wrong
political horse so what this these
organizations do is to very much limit
the range of policies that are even that
ISM discussable that's right and what is
legitimated
in the in the minds of the American
people and also in Congress but there's
a parallel thing that goes on in public
opinion shaping to is they're not I
think so and I think the important thing
to say is that is precisely what you
just did and that is it's not that these
people sort of just pour opinions into
our head but rather that they try to
manage the limits of respectable opinion
which are fairly wide as those things go
in the world but nonetheless kinds of
liberal opinions and kinds of ultra
conservative opinions get labeled in
some way as to utopian or to kooky or
unamerican and too extreme or erratic
right and we can know you know the the
the way the ultra concerns do it is to
call it anti you know call it communist
or socialist or unamerican the moderates
say sounds awfully utopian to me or
sounds awfully academic the appeal is to
the practical if we can legitimate
something as practical and American then
it's okay but very definitely there's a
constant argument goes on to try to keep
some pin
is not respectable and to see that you
have to look historically at some
particular argument and here I just say
quickly that the best example of that
involves the famous economist John
Maynard Keynes and his views about the
use of government spending to to
stabilize a capitalist economy there are
many ways of being there are many
policies that follow from Keynes there
are many different things you could do
in via Keynesian but what happened in
America from 1935 to 1965 was
essentially an intellectual struggle in
which the business community was saw
that a very conservative Keynesianism
would make sense to them but that a more
liberal Keynesianism
they didn't want they didn't want to
accept and furthermore weren't forced to
accept because our working class is not
powerful enough
organizationally to force a liberal kind
of Keynesianism such as happens in a
sweden say so basically what was what
Keynes said in the middle 30s slowly got
whittled down you know just the way you
describe got whittled down and so we
have a very conservative kind of
Keynesianism and now right now in
America we are seeing the amazing thing
whether intentionally or not we are
seeing the amazing and complete
application of Keynesian economics to
the American economy by somebody who a
totally rejects Keynes and claims these
a supply-side ER and C doesn't
understand economics and this is Ronald
Reagan but what has happened is that
we've just had a total Keynesian
recovery in the United States because
the key thing in Kaine is you run a
deficit and you do government spending
now that's what Ronald Reagan has done
but it's all of course been military
spending we call it a military
Keynesianism Ronald Reagan is behaving
as a Keynesian even while saying he's
not and he may not know he's a Keynesian
I don't know if he I know you never done
so there is there are a whole set of
mechanisms that legitimate some opinions
and make other opinions seem far out or
not worth studying the mass media do
this to my studies the mass media I find
that once this policy has been
set that the media will follow up on
this and you will not find any
discussion on anything on the other side
of this preset agenda by these people
you're talking about or if it is
discussed it's highly criticized but
generally it's just ignored in their in
their one another aspect of determining
whether a ruling class is also a
governing class or the upper class is
also a ruling class that is you have to
look at where the decision makers come
from see if the prime decision makers
come from this ruling class or the
people whom this ruling class is
selected right where I think that that's
another very useful way of understanding
about power because it's the most
visible to us that is we can watch
people we may we right now are not we
don't know what's being talked about in
the set usually at the National Security
Council or in the private meetings of
the White House but we sure do know
who's there and to give you an example
if we take the Secretary of Treasury as
a important position and we look at a
few of them for instance under Kennedy
who ran on a platform of getting the
country moving again we've got to get
beyond this stodgy Republican
establishment so on and yet when he was
elected the person he put in charge of
Treasury was a landing see Douglas
Dillon from a man worth several hundred
billions of dollars who from a major
investment house in in New York when we
jump to Jimmy Carter who was our
populist and Hamilton Jordan assured us
that we were going to see new faces in
fact the person that we got is our
Secretary of Treasury was a man named W
Michael Blumenthal who was the head of
Bendix corporation a trustee of the
Council on Foreign Relations a trustee
of the committee for Economic
Development trustee of Princeton
University and a member of the
Trilateral Commission and he becomes our
Secretary of Treasury now Ronald Reagan
comes in and he's going to get rid of
the mess in Washington from a
neoconservative perspective but our
Secretary of Treasury is a man named Don
Regan I was it was his first Secretary
of Treasury as you know and and Donald
Regan was from Merrill Lynch he was a
member of the Council on Foreign
Relations he was a trustee of the
committee for Economic Development he
was a trustee of the Business Roundtable
and what I'm saying of course with those
examples is that when we look at the
cabinet level appointments of the past
40 years at the least but we could go
back further but if we look at the last
40 years that whether it's a Republican
or a Democrat whether it's a populist or
a neoconservative whatever particular
ticket they run on or ideology they run
on in order to attract a coalition of
voters when they turn to the question of
governing when they turn to the question
of how are they going to implement a set
of policies they do as your question
suggests they turn to the same group of
people that have been both made
sophisticated about issues in these
policy discussion groups and have been
made legitimate in these policy
discussion groups as having more than
just the perspective of their particular
corporation but also that they are
States persons that is that they are
people that look at the broader picture
so the continuity of these people is
very great I also want to add to that
Frank now as you got me kind of rolling
on it is that this also involves experts
in America not just
multimillionaires and corporate
executives but very important experts
are part of this power elite that we're
talking about as well and and what I'm
then saying is that that councils on
Foreign Relations committees for
economic development so on actually have
basically a monopoly of the respectable
expertise in the United States the
people that are sound and sensible these
are all in quotes respectable South
kissinger being wanted and that's
exactly where i'm headed is to henry
kissinger if we look at the career of
henry kissinger we might say well only
in america in one way yes because here
is a person who's a escapee from from
nazi germany who
by going to school here by doing well at
Harvard we can say look at him he's been
very important and he had but here is
the other part of kissinger's career
that's so important while he was at
Harvard he was seen by a man named
McGeorge Bundy who was the Dean of the
faculty the head of the faculty and from
a prominent Boston family is father's a
corporation lawyer in other words he's a
well-to-do person that happened to be in
the academic world and he called his
friends at the Council on Foreign
Relations and he said you know this guy
Kissinger is a bright young guy and he
could really be useful in some of the
discussion groups and so Kissinger was
invited to be in these discussion groups
and Nelson Rockefeller was really taken
with Kissinger and he basically then
hired him to write things for him and to
write things for panels of experts that
the Rockefellers set up well in the late
60s the interesting thing is that of
course that Richard Nixon appointed
Kissinger as his foreign policy adviser
now the first reason that's interesting
is that supposedly Nixon and kisses me
that Nixon Rockefeller were so different
they had all their political conflicts
and yet Nixon was perfectly willing to
hire what seemed to be quotes Nelson
Rockefellers man but beyond that the
interesting thing is that two years
after the election at a point when
Kissinger star was was quite high
Hubert Humphrey was interviewed was
taught they were talking about what he
would have done if he was president he
said well it's funny that one of the
things I was going to do was a point
Henry Kissinger he had talked to Henry
Kissinger before the election saying if
I'm elected will you be my foreign
policy adviser my point is of course
whether we get Nixon or whether we get
Humphrey there was one thing we were
sure we were going to get and that was
Kissinger it was a Rockefeller man yeah
but basically by that time of course
he's known too many of these corporate
people his expertise is very useful to
them
he's been legitimated through being part
of these organizations like the council
but then let's take it down to what I
think also interesting in terms of
continuity of a power structure take it
down to the early 1980s
Reagan Ronald Reagan in part ran on a
platform that was practically running
against Henry Kissinger one of the
things the very conservative Republicans
do not like is what they call Eastern
establishment and one of their favorite
pet peeves within Eastern establishment
is the Council on Foreign Relations and
one part of that is Henry Kissinger well
what do we end up with within a year or
two we have Henry Kissinger as head of
the President's Commission on Central
America in other words Ronald Reagan
also then hires Henry Kissinger so when
you just trace the career of that man
you then see the continuity in the power
structure but at the same time we're
back to our earlier point about are we
just talking about individuals no we're
not because we have to understand that
Kissinger first was at a very important
institution called Harvard which is one
of the main reservoirs of expertise as
well as a place for upward mobility
where experts are seen by members of the
ruling class whether they're McGeorge
Bundy or whether they're trustees the
University then he went to the Council
on Foreign Relations where as part of a
discussion group of 20 or 30 people from
all over the country people from the CIA
people from the State Department people
from corporations people from law firms
other academic experts and in that
situation he they say this person sees
the world the way we do and he has
information that's that's very useful to
us and so it's this institutional
setting that he's moved through that
brings him into other power structures
bill can we move now to the economic
foundation is a power struggle well I
think that that we had a simple phrase
they are the owners and managers of
large corporations and banks I think
that the base of power there are two key
bases of power in the United States one
is a large corporation and the second is
the federal government in Washington
when I talk for instance about a Council
on Foreign Relations it's not Council on
Foreign Relations is not a place of
power it is a place where powerful
people discuss when I talk about
Bohemian Club and it's Bohemian Grove
retreat in Northern California the
Bohemian Grove is not a place of power
you are not powerful because you were at
the Bohemian Grove you're at the feel
Heat Bohemian Grove because you were
powerful and you are powerful because
you're an owner and manager of a large
corporation so that's the root of of the
power in the United States there is what
I call a corporate community which means
that the large corporations in America
are interconnected through ownership
through sharing of information through
putting out products together through
having the same directors through hiring
each other's managers that it truly is
in that sense of community and and they
are relatively tightly knit they they
not only share that a common interest in
making a lot of money but they also
believe they have common enemies which
is very important in making a community
- and their common enemies are
environmentalist labor and of course
those dreadful bureaucrats in Washington
who in the American ideology are
constantly harassing these poor
beleaguered entrepreneurs who are just
struggling to to deliver jobs for us
make the third billion dollars yeah so I
think then when we say when you see that
they and we do know this from interviews
that they see themselves constantly
under pressure from as I say labor
environmentalists and from government
trying to regulate them that gives them
a feeling of we against them but but
more than that they're not just I don't
just have you know one corporation and
somebody else another one we share that
corporation we have share it and
ownership we share directorship and so
on so I do think that is the base of
power in the United States dug in it and
that is something that people really
don't like to say that is they want to
see power in individuals and not in
General Motors and General Electric and
Exxon and and Chase Manhattan Bank but
actually that's what I think the power
is then from there people like Henry
Kissinger become very
to articulate the general policies that
those people need to continue the
corporate community does develop a set
of generalist may be a person may be for
instance you start out running a
particular corporation you're doing a
fine job and you're asked to be on a
coupler three other corporate boards and
from being on all those different
corporate boards you start to see the
bigger picture and now people say Frank
would you go to Washington and testify
and try to explain what to these
government officials what we need you
become a generalist for the corporations
as a whole and you may leave your
particular job in any one corporation
but you're still part of the corporate
community you're not some individual
floating around out there
you have an institutional base you have
a reference group in this corporate
community that's right so many people
are from the Bechtel corporation or in
the Reagan administration Secretary of
State the Secretary of Defense with feds
right and a couple of others and
certainly they haven't lost their
loyalty to the Bechtel corporation the
Bechtel corporation is doing really well
with the government contracts I want to
ask you this this seems like a
contradiction in a way in one hand we
say that the government is dominated and
controlled by the wealthy powerful
people from the American ruling class
but on the other hand we see that the
business community grouses a lot about
the bureaucrats in Washington now are
they
grousing and complaining about their own
people in the way they run the
government or are is it like a couple of
books I've seen where it's the inside
directors the managers of these
corporations who have basically their
one corporation uppermost in mine
complaining about the way the their
upper their betters the ruling class in
Washington is running the country for
the benefit of themselves and the
country so you see this division that
the absolutely highest level compared to
the highest level of just merely one
corporation I think that's a really
complex and important question because
it does seem to be anomaly that
businessmen say that they're powerless
and yet they have all of this money
they're the ones appointed to
governments on so why is it that
businessmen say they are powerless I've
thought about that a lot and read a lot
about it and I've interviewed people and
I think that it has several levels to it
as an answer first of all we have to
come we have to start with the fact that
all Americans tend to have the view that
government is awful and rapacious it's
like that's what we always complain
about that's that's just sort of the way
we talk for instance in the Reagan
administration they're constantly
talking against big government
constantly complaining about government
and yet
they're constantly getting all of these
subsidies and being you know using the
government ways that's useful to them so
in one way in one part of it the answer
is that it's it's it's just part of our
rhetoric in America but in a next level
and this analysis comes from a political
scientist who does not think there's a
cohesive power lead a man named grant
McConnell he makes the point that by
constantly criticizing these government
officials it keeps them on the defensive
you see so it's a very good strategy if
I walk in and I say Doug you're against
me aren't you this is a no bill I'm not
against you Doug you're always against
me you always seem to be not doing the
stuff that really helps our corporation
this constant complaining about
government keeps the government people
kind of on the defensive and proving
that they're all right
one of the best things that Kennedy ever
did for the point of view of the
business community was during his
argument with you the steel companies
over over the over price rise that they
did he made a comment to somebody my
father always told me businessmen were
sons of [ __ ]
well they constantly then used that on
Kennedy and he constantly had to prove
that he was okay when right and there's
a wonderful book
on the free-enterprise errs that points
out that corporations did fantastically
well under Kennedy so it's I think it's
useful to do that now but there's
another level and that is you see in the
American government the people that are
the day-to-day employees do come from
the the middle levels of our society the
values of our country are such that it's
no great individual fulfillment to
become a government official because we
look down on government so much they're
just politicians and bureaucrats if this
were a European country with an
aristocratic tradition members of the
upper class might say gee I think I'll
go into the civil service they would say
and say I'm thinking concretely here of
England and of France so that there
might be many people in the government
as permanent employees who were from the
same class as the business people but in
America that wouldn't be something you
would do if you had lots of money you
went to this nice prep school now you've
got this Yale degree and you say what am
I going to do with my life you're not
going to say oh I'm going to go work for
the government
unless it's the State Department there
there's some tradition of some
upper-class involvement so they aren't
part of the same networks and in that
sense there's always the possibility
that these government bureaucrats might
we don't quite know so we don't maybe
quite you see then trust them there's
that there's a residual idealism in the
country at different times in history
during the New Deal
during Kennedy in the 1960s a lot of
people were influenced to believe that
we needed a stronger government that the
government should serve the people
there's a populist tradition in the
United States and so some government
quote-unquote bureaucrats we might say
employees have assimilated these beliefs
that puts them in conflict with
corporate power there's also an anti
corporate tradition in the United States
is not that everyone emulates and
celebrates and goes along that a
corporation the truth the reason I think
your books have had impact in some
quarters is because they have played to
this distrust of excessive corporate
power and so you get this at times
operative in the government where they
actually are conflicts between the state
and the government and there is a
relative autonomy to some of the
government regulatory agencies mostly
they're packed by people from business
sharing the interests of business but
occasionally you'll get a Nicholas
Johnson in the FCC who really believes
that the media should be do you rule
than the common interests it will go
against right the network's so you get
this kind of contradiction I think then
absolutely right and it's by looking
precisely at cases like the one you just
named or if we looked at the Federal
Trade Commission in the late sick at
late 70s when Michael perchick took it
over and he started to really use it to
try to enforce various kinds of laws and
regulations on the corporations and they
fought back against the FCC but Doug I
think you're absolutely right I think
that is the final level of understanding
businessmen's concerns and feeling of
powerlessness and that's precisely the
point that at because Americans believe
that government is potentially bad and
domineering and because of the populist
democratic tradition of America
basically it says our government you see
is founded on all the people
government's the past were founded on
the divinities or on kings or the
Parliament founded a government but ours
clearly says power is in the people and
what that means is that in any American
business person dominating that
government there's a certain way in
which it's illegitimate and the final
point then that we think we pick up in
interviews and and and a couple of
people have written about this even for
the 1920s which we all assume was the
heyday of business there was always that
fear that you'd I think that you well
put that namely the people might take
over this government so in that sense
it's not it's not theirs in the
legitimacy sense and so there's always
that concern with the underlying
populist
kind of thing and it does manifest
itself sometimes then in the
in the election of liberal people and
and and then the important of liberal
officials and you know when when we were
talking earlier about campaign finance
and I was talking about people that rose
to the heights in terms of running for
president running for vice president it
is also the case but we can see it we
can all name some that there are elected
officials in the United States who are
not part of the power lead and they very
often do oppose their position so I have
no doubt there are pro-labor there are
pro-environmental there are very liberal
elected officials at various levels in
our society and that does create then
real conflict so that my point would be
it's not that there aren't such people
there my point is they usually lose just
as you say with them in fact if we look
at the FCC or if we look at the FTC if
we look at various kinds of attempts to
create for instance the Consumer
Protection Agency with some teeth what
happens is we oh [ __ ] that we that we
eventually lose they grind us down and
they grind us down because they have
this institutional base behind them they
have more staying power and furthermore
eventually with these liberal elected
officials they constantly run at these
people one of the things that's so
interesting to me is to watch the way in
which a liberal politician will come to
Congress and if he or she starts to
really vote in a way that's constantly
annoying to the business community they
will quote target that person they will
constantly send a lot of money to
candidates that are running against this
person in the district so keeping the
person on the defensive letting them
know one false step and they're going to
eliminate so is in my view is not of a
power structure that's sort of sitting
there and it's all signed sealed and
delivered and never challenged in
America the power structure is
constantly challenged but it basically
constantly wins except on you know
occasionally it doesn't but so so there
is real conflict in American I think
your point really brings that out well
and and I think that it's important not
to deny that
what is important see who wins that's
the key to this is that we do have a
pluralistic society but we do not have a
pluralistic economic and political
structure I think that's excellent I
think that we I think we have the
paradox over the last 20 years that a
lot of the social movements would have
happened a lot of the events have made
in some way in some ways it's a very
open society at the individual personal
a kind of level and yet I continue to
believe we have the same corporate power
structure and I don't think it's
necessarily a contradiction in terms
that that my access to certain kind of
information my right to do things as an
individual which is a very important
part of liberalism that that could be
increased in the society and it has been
for for minorities for women for gays
for handicapped those kinds of liberal
individual freedoms could actually be in
some way increased and we could still be
relatively powerless when we talk about
whether a group is ruling or not we have
to look at three or four indicators of
power one of course is we've taught
we've hit upon when we talked about
wealth if a group is a dominant group or
a ruling group we would expect them to
have more of what people value in a
society and certainly this upper social
class we've been talking about has more
wealth
it has more income it certainly has
access to the best education and health
care and so on so on all the measures of
who benefits I think there's that shows
that they are a ruling class because we
would all like to be a lot richer we'd
all like to be a lot more secure in our
economic circumstance but I also think
that we can show that these people are a
ruling class when we look at the kinds
of policies that are implemented by the
federal government and these policies
range from subsidies for specific
corporations and industries tax breaks a
little shaving on regulations and so on
on up to more general policies policies
that I think basically benefit large
corporation
as a group and that means kinds of
foreign policies that maximize the
possibility of an investment overseas
policies at the domestic level that that
maximize the possibility of a tranquil
and happy and docile workforce numerous
kinds of policy I also think that if we
look at the history of any politician
any politician America that rises to the
very top that what we find is that a
certain point in their career they
become very involved with the people
that we're talking about here and and
that the upper class becomes essential
to that politician in terms of the
financing of his or her campaigns and
that means things like financing their
travel giving them money in advance so
they can schedule all their television
time giving them the kind of money that
allows them to hire experts and
basically then it gives any politician
that gives it gets involved with these
people a leg up in any particular
political race and these politicians are
not going to have a set of policy
stances that are going to be a new
mikhyl to to the ruling group Jimmy
Carter's a perfect Jimmy Carter's a fine
example and we could say that he's a
nice example in terms of the fact that
it was not really until he got to the
state level that he got involved with
the well-to-do of Atlanta and and then
some well-to-do people Atlanta thought
that he might be potentially a
national-level politician and and got
him involved with the Trilateral
Commission where he met a lot of people
who in turn national elites that gave
him a lot of money but if we look at
Nixon Nixon is another kind of
interesting example in that well-to-do
Republicans in the Los Angeles area
we're looking for a candidate to
challenge a liberal in Congress and they
interviewed literally put out the word
that they wanted to interview candidates
and they decided on Nixon and
bankrolled Nixon from that point for it
but but let's take Hubert Humphrey
Humphrey was a liberal person who I
think in early parts of his career was
not heavily involved with the people I'm
talking about but once he wanted to go
beyond the state level it's real clear
in terms of his campaign finance that
that he was involved with a relative
handful of people that in 1968 for
instance lent him 20 25 people lent him
a couple million dollars for his
campaign so they say you look at the
Liberals or you can look at Ronald
Reagan you can look at Nixon you look at
Carter and as they when they decide they
want to go beyond a local or state level
milieu they get involved with with the
people we're talking about they have to
otherwise they can't they don't have the
financial they just don't have the
financial backing it's like thinking of
politics as this real high-stakes poker
game that you have to have a few million
dollars to be to be in it and you see
this is where we get back to this
question about is there a power
structure Americans are used to thinking
well if there's a power structure we
wouldn't even be allowed to be in
politics but in America you're allowed
to run for president you can run for
anything you want there's just one thing
you better have several million dollars
or access to people that that have
several million dollar so you see we can
say in the 1l is very fair anybody can
run but in fact not anybody can when you
get down to the specifics of the matter
so we have a formally open and liberal
system but in practice the way things
work out is that the rich get richer and
they are able to continue a set of
policies that that maximize their
advantages it is also the case that we
can see it we can all name some that
there are elected officials in the
United States who are not part of the
power elite and they very often do
oppose their position so I have no doubt
there are Pro
there are pro-environmental there are
very liberal elected officials at
various levels in our society and that
does create then real conflict so that
my point would be is not that there
aren't such people there my point is
they usually lose just as you say with
them in effect if we look at the FCC if
we look at the FTC if we look at various
kinds of attempts to create for instance
a Consumer Protection Agency with some
teeth
what happens is we OSHA that we that we
eventually lose they grind this down and
they grind us down because they have
this institutional base behind them they
have more staying power and furthermore
eventually with these liberal elected
officials they constantly run at these
people one of the things that's so
interesting to me is to watch the
language a liberal politician will come
to Congress and if he or she starts to
really vote in a way that's constantly
annoying to the business community they
will quote target that person they will
constantly send a lot of money to
candidates that are running against this
person in the district so keeping the
person on the defensive letting them
know that one false step and they're
going to eliminate so in my view is not
of a power structure that's sort of
sitting there and it's all signed sealed
and delivered and never challenged in
America the power structure is
constantly challenged but it basically
constantly wins except on don't patient
but so so there is real conflict in
American I think your point really
brings that out well and and I think
that it's important not to deny that
what is important see who wins that's
the key to this is that we do have a
pluralistic society but we do not have a
pluralistic economic and political
structure I think that's excellent I
think that we I think we have the
paradox over the last 20 years that a
lot of the social movements that have
happened a lot of the events have made
in some way in some ways this is a very
open society at the individual personal
a kind of level and yet I continue to
believe we have the same corporate power
structure and I don't think it's
necessarily a contradiction in terms
that that my access to certain kind of
information my right to do things as an
individual which is a very important
part of liberalism that that could be
increased in the society and it has been
for for minorities for women for gays
for handicapped those kinds of liberal
individual freedoms could actually be in
some way increased and we could still be
relatively powerless so far you've
talked about a cohesion within the
ruling class but are there significant
conflicts at times the Vietnam War for
instance there were two opposing views
were people the establishment took Pro
and anti-war positions I think in
Reagan's
income tax reform obviously there's no
cohesion or they can't come to agreement
how do you explain conflicts within the
ruling class what are the main divisions
if any okay and what forms do they take
once we have set this general kind of
framework that we've been talking about
in which we affect know that these
corporate people feel a lot of cominis
from there we can go on to say that they
do argue about various kinds of things
and that I do think that we see some
relatively long lasting kinds of
different differences of opinions over
specific kinds of issues and you
mentioned the division of opinion that
developed over the Vietnam War which i
think was was very real and very
important at the same time from my point
of view the debate over what to do
went on and precisely the organizations
were talking about that is put and put
put more specifically in the early 60s I
think there was complete consensus in
the power leap that it was necessary to
go into Vietnam as the war went more and
more badly real significant difference
of opinion developed in the late 60s
particularly in the face of the Tet
Offensive and this manifested itself
then in very vehement arguments at a
place like the Council on Foreign
Relations and experts came there for
instance one person Samuel Huntington
from Harvard and he would say the
discussion groups things like this he
said
things have changed we got to look at
this differently first of all there is a
sino-soviet split second there is no big
Communist Party now in Indonesia that's
that's been wiped out and that that
makes less of a threat in Southeast Asia
in in general thirdly there hasn't been
the spread of the Cuban Revolution in
Latin America and then fourthly we're
now facing a major ghetto uprising in
this country real unsettling things are
happening and the peace movement and the
peace movement is the next thing ever
faced with this and given what's that
what it's going to cost us to win in
Vietnam we should get out of that war
gradually now what's interesting is that
a set of people that were known around
Washington as the wise men these were
people at Johnson brought in once a
month
the wise men switched their views on the
war well who whether about a dozen of
them ten or ten of them at least we're
in this Council on Foreign Relations
reinvestment bankers three corporate
lawyers a couple retired military all
had been in and out of government in and
out of corporations and they said that
they heard all the government officials
talk about what was what the what was
needed after tip and they went to
Johnson and they said to him don't send
more troops to Vietnam according to all
accounts he was kind of stunned by this
and one week later he went on the TV and
he announced he would not run for
president again and that was kind of a
crucial kind of turning point I
definitely a division of opinion
developed on how to deal with this
situation and they turned they changed
their mind now there are also
longer-lasting kinds of divisions of
opinion between people that in terms of
the American political era c'n political
spectrum that we would call moderate
kinds of conservatives they are either
conservative Democrats or moderate
Republicans their opinions differ from
those of very conservative people
sometimes called ultra conservative the
moderate conservatives
come I believe from the biggest and most
international corporations in America by
and large these corporations are in
favor more and more free trade they are
willing to see some kinds of social
welfare policies used they believe that
there is some validity do a Keynesian
economic the alter conservative people
tend to come from smaller corporations
and privately held corporations that is
where the family owns that the stock is
not publicly traded and they tend to be
in very competitive kinds of national
markets that they sell their products in
some region of America and are trying to
get overseas or don't have the money to
get overseas those people have been
historically very isolationist on
foreign policy they have been opposed to
the slightest welfare state developments
including Social Security and these
people tend to believe that a deficit in
spending is the work of the devil
okay anti labor - Oh any concessions to
labor whereas our moderates are willing
to bring them in or at least the
conservative labor some of them yeah I
think they're I want to say that I think
I was a little wrong in some things that
I wrote in the nineteen in the early 70s
particularly in 1970 I had I had had the
understanding from my earlier work that
that the people I've just described as
moderates were moderates towards unions
they are moderate towards labor in a
sense of willing to improve welfare
benefits willing to change things that
workers complain about within the
factory but they do not like unions
either another know part of this power
structure likes unions and the reason
we've had unions unconvinced is because
of the power of workers in the
industries that have unions one of the
things that I think is very important to
understand about the
Reagan administration is that I believe
that the kinds of people I've
characterized as moderate conservatives
are basically the people running that
administration people like George Shultz
like Donald Regan like Caspar Weinberger
like Baldrige at Malcolm Baldrige at
Commerce they are basically what I call
moderate conservatives the people in the
second and third level positions in the
Reagan government are ultra
conservatives that then you say well
look at the labor policies the labor
policies are very conservative because
unions are less powerful now the
moderates like the idea of stomping on
musician but they couldn't do it in the
past so you couldn't stomp on unions in
the Nixon administration not because
Nixon was was friendly the unions but
because in the face of the unrest in
America his whole appeal was to hardhats
these are the true American he wasn't
going to attack unions when he was
trying to build them as a base against
these awful students who were for
demonstrating but now we have a
different situation that Reagan faces we
have a time of peace and quiets within
our country maybe there are people
grumbling or certainly people become in
poor and I think that's a tragedy but
there's nobody disrupting America so and
furthermore there's no war going on out
there somewhere and furthermore there is
the internationalization of production
that has led to an enormous number of
jobs going overseas which has decimated
the steel Union the auto union and some
of the other in that context you can go
get the Union and that's why I think
Reagan is doing it not because he's more
conservative than these previous
administration but because the situation
has changed in such a way it's now
possible to go after the Union would you
say also it's because that there is no
big union uprising or like the water
back in the early 1900's and the 30s the
you know the labor struggles are
centrally essentially over as far as the
labor hierarchy is concerned so they've
even brought them into some of these
elite organizations that you've been
talking about that's a betrayal at
orokin
it's absolutely true that the leadership
of the AF of l-cio is invited to sit on
the board of a Rockefeller Foundation is
invited to be in these discussion groups
like trilateral commission or Council on
Foreign Relations I think that some of
that is is definitely part of the
picture but it's like it's more like
once there are unions and we've got to
live with them then we'll talk to these
guys but we're certainly not really
accepting them and if the time comes
that we can undercut them further we
sure will and that so I think on
flexibility of the ruling class that if
there is ferment from below if there is
a challenge to the system they will
retrench and give a bit so they can
maintain their control but just as soon
as the opposition is weak then they'll
push it back and that's my view about
the moderate conservatives that is they
the squeaky wheel gets the grease and
when there was a real disruption in
American society starting with the civil
rights movement then the anti-war
movement Ghetto Uprising they were
willing and I mean by force - yeah they
were forced to than they were willing to
have a Family Assistance Plan for
instance they were willing to see better
health care national health care these
were actually programs advocated by this
organization called the committee for
economic development but when the unrest
want went away the policy position of
the committee for economic development
changed in this much more conservative a
kind of way I think it's an important
kind of flexibility that means that
there that the possibility of reform
keeps the system stable you see what's
implied by your comment which I agree
with or I claim as implied is before
these people I got it from your book I
know but the most important issue is
power is control in other words if I'm
going to make a few million dollars left
for a few years okay but I want to keep
my situation I want to keep the general
system running you see in the face of
unrest there is another possibility you
can put all the people in jail you can
repress them you can do very negative
kinds of thing and there are some times
people would advocate those kinds of
solutions and there are laws in the
books which would permit this if the
garden right side
they work very well I mean often it
folks war on run or rebellion it has
that possibility but even in the middle
1930s and here I'm jumping to a time of
extreme labor unrest perhaps the most
militant time that there were that there
was only a short kind of window of
opportunity to use the common parlance
of that when sit-down strikes were
legitimate in the minds of most
Americans within within a years of those
sit-down strikes the public opinion was
opposed to them even in the 1930s I
think that a majority of American people
were still rural small town workers a
lot of the white-collar workers they
were not crazy about the union movement
I think that it can very conservative
solutions could have been could have
been enacted against the union movement
if there had been a different
administration if there had been a
Republican administration if there had
not been Democrat administrations in
Michigan and Pennsylvania I think we
would have had continued conflict in in
those labor struggles I say that in the
context the fact that after US Steel was
organized after General Motors was
organized then they in the case the
Steel Workers Union they went into
Illinois Indiana and Ohio to try to
organize little steel and they did not
succeed there were many people killed
jailed in Ohio every labor organizer
that they sent into Ohio was put into
jail at one time or another and it was
not until World War two under the when
Roosevelt said we've got to have we've
got to stop this labor strife to fight
this war that those that those steel
companies were organized the one of them
never to follow logically from your
analysis of the power structure they're
the only way that progressive political
change and reform can come in the United
States is through political struggle
from below in which the power structure
is forced to make certain concessions
and certain reforms to stop unrest from
growing into outright rebellion or
revolution that they themselves are not
so generous like
pro-labor if you don't have a strong
union movement strong social movements
and agitation actual struggle for a
change the power structure is going to
rule on unopposed and do more or less
within their entry there's nothing
against everyone else no they're going
to continue to go through their routines
from the way we as sociologists talk to
talk about that point is in terms of the
question of disrupting people's routines
that is basically a society is organized
in a set of institutions and roles in
such a way that people can go about
their everyday business what that means
in terms of people watching this program
they can get up in the morning and they
can go to school they can look forward
to graduating they can say okay I'm able
to get a job I'll be able to have a
family I'll be able to have my vacations
my weekends living in that ordinary life
is very compelling it draws people into
those routine for anything to happen to
lead to change there has to be in some
way a disruption of those routines and
I'm using that very generally because if
we look at what happened that changed
America in the 30s it was a massive
disruption of of a non-union America by
this incredible Depression there was
unions were a very small matter in the
1920 but when this economic system would
no longer work and people were thrown
out of their routines they started to
vote Democrats are to vote then when
they voted they voted Democrat they
started to organize unions but it was
that disruption and Citians you know we
get very concrete the front of the key
dramatic elements in the early 1937
right it started 1937 was a sit-in a
General Motors Factory in Flint Michigan
which meant the Capitals could not go
through their routines they could not go
in and make get these cars made and the
sit-in movement then flashed across the
country in all kinds of other factories
and and really gave this tremendous
impetus to to the Union but now let's
look at the 60s the 60s led to a lot of
changes not
because of Labor disruption not because
of economic failure but first of all
because of the fact that there had been
created a small black middle-class in
the south that wanted to insist that the
country live up to its its liberal
values and how did they do it they did
it at the key point by disrupting
people's routines they sat down in lunch
counters and said we will not move we
shall not be moved and that sit-in
movement once again spread to buses to
all kinds of facilities where people sat
in and they disrupted the lives of these
people they could not in Birmingham for
instance they boycott the downtown they
marched through the downtown now no
longer can you just go downtown and shop
can you go to your office you got to
worry something going to happen the
anti-war movement did the same thing the
anti-war movement disrupted the routines
of administrators of faculty indeed of
of the likes of Secretary of Defense
McNamara he could not go to Harvard and
collect his honorary degree because
there were people out in the streets
protesting jostling his car hissing and
booing is on that is what makes things
happen now I'm not advocating by this
say for instance violence I'm describing
and I happen to believe personally that
the best kinds of disruptions are
nonviolent direct action but I'm saying
but stepping back from you know my
advocacy there again into the role of
describer or analysts as what I'm saying
is that when we do see change what we
see is in some way people's routines
have been disrupted and what will cause
that as economic dislocation Wars
sometimes will be some kind of an
accident that will disrupt people's
routines a major oil spill a major
radiation accident clear accident like
we're seeing now so yeah and it makes
people right if the questions people out
of their routines and and also in the
face of these accidents what happens
that's very interesting in terms of our
normal everyday beliefs is that an
accident makes it very hard to manage
the news tremendous amount of what comes
across the media is when a spokesperson
for the State Department or the press
whatever stands up at this carefully
staged press conference and tells us
what's happening or is going to happen
the corporation releases a statement
saying we're now going to build this
kind of car whenever in the face of an
accident
they can't sort of get their viewpoint
they can't get their line together and
often will unravel for them and we get a
very revealing picture then of a power
structure in the face of a break-in
routine and of course Watergate was a
nice example of that and finally we end
up of all things with the tapes of
Richard Nixon's conversations in the
White House now that was over an
accident when a man it wasn't supposed
to be arrested was arrested you lie
about it
you don't have your story real straight
and that leads to another thing and it
just kept unraveling in this wonderful
kind of in that case it was a disruption
in their their levels and it spread in a
way that then gave us this incredible
information about how the power
structure operated another example the
way in which we've disruption is
important but also we learned much about
the power structure involves Daniel
Ellsberg who was a policy analyst for
the Defense Department and had worked
for a think tank called the RAND
Corporation had often been an advisor to
major policymakers at these discussion
groups Ellsberg was from a union family
but had gone on to go to Harvard and
become this big expert but in the face
of the anti-war movement it rekindled in
him he he reported his feelings of his
background and he decided that the war
was so wrong that he was going to reveal
the origins this war by putting the
Pentagon Papers out in the general
public and so in a word we learned this
amazing detail of of the fact that how
the whole war policy was made the fact
that they were saying one thing and
doing another in other words they knew
the problems they're going to have
winning that war at the very time they
were saying it was going to be a
lead-pipe cinch so but Ellsberg just
wasn't somebody that suddenly decided to
give these papers out it was only the
disruption in the society that gradually
got to him in terms of kind of stripping
away the veneer
that he had learned that made him then
Rhea denta fie with people of that we're
struggling in this society so accidents
scandals break routines and major social
disruptions like a civil rights movement
or a ghetto uprising which involves the
massive movement of black people from
from south to north that's one of the
largest migrations of the people in
history in such a short time and that
unsettles a social system here are
people who basically rural people and
farm people all of a sudden in inner
cities in another atmosphere namely in
the north and that was a disruption of
the cities partly mostly because of
course the white people didn't like it
and then there was all the white flight
any rate that's what then creates the
opportunities for people to to do battle
with this with these power structures
and in that context the moderate
conservatives are willing to bend and
and in that sense we get reforms in our
system which may be lost later which
very definitely can be lost later and
that's the kind of the story of what's
happened with the Reagan years that is
the disruption is gone patriotism is
back there's no wars in that context the
the Conservatives then all of a sudden
talk about how well these were just
liberal experience just experiments they
were just a bunch of intellectuals
trying out ideas in other words they
totally ignore the fact that that these
things were all done in the face of real
real pressure and they are of course
trying to undercut all those programs
let's turn now to the local level what
is the difference between the power
structure on the local and the national
level and the differences between the
possibilities for individual
participation and impact locally and
nationally I think that local power
structures are rooted not in large
corporations that produce a product
which is which is where the national
power structure is rooted but rather
local power structures are rooted in
real estate in land in development at
the local level we have what we like to
call a growth machine the national level
we have a power Lea rooted in large
corporation
at the local level we have a growth
machine that's rooted in the attempt to
increase the value of land and what they
want is growth and which intensifies the
use of their land
now that means then that we have to look
at a complex of landowners developers
real estate salespeople and so on and
mortgage banks savings and loans tied
around ground development that's what
happens at the local level all ippolit
the key issues to a local power
structure are the water board the
parking and transportation board the
Planning Board the Zoning Board that the
real politics for local power structure
the other issues are for them
symbolic some of things that concern
other citizens but the local power
structure is concerned with with growth
now the local power structure does
relate to the national power structure
in a very important way and that is that
what a local power structure tries to do
is to attract national capital that is
they try to prepare the land their area
so it will be attractive to the new
building the new high-rise building that
General Motors wants to put up somewhere
so we try to as a local city they try to
say look we have the cheapest land that
you could want we have a very nice and
docile labor force we have low taxes so
all these local growth machines compete
with each other to try to get the
General Motors factory the Exxon office
building or more generally the new
campus of the University of Texas they
try to get the new new Defense
Department installation because if you
bring one of those major capital kinds
of structures into your city it will
mean new jobs for people
it will mean then more money more
spending for the local retailers and you
will then your land will be valuable
because now the local retailer is making
more money so you can charge it more
rent on the building that you've rented
it so I think that's really important to
understand that that
the land-based nature of local power
structures versus this more capital
based nature of totally capital based
nature of the national power structure
I've just then suggested that there's a
lot of commonality between them but they
that they have reasons to work together
but you also must understand that
there's tensions between them because if
say the labor force becomes very radical
in a given City General Motors might say
ok we're leaving we're going overseas or
we're going to Tennessee and that at
that point they can leave behind a
broken local growth machine so the local
growth machine often finds itself angry
with national level capital when it
leaves
so there's tension between them as well
as well as cooperation now it's also
important to understand that at the
local level the primary tension is
created between the growth machine is it
attempts to expand and the rest of the
people who are trying to live their
lives in their neighborhoods at the
national level we have a lot of conflict
between the owners of corporations and
other people as workers as workers we
want more wages which of course for the
capitalist point of view is inflationary
we want various kinds of benefits which
from their point of view might make us
lazy and not work as hard and so on so
we have a capital labor tension in
national politics that underlies a lot
of the fights over welfare and inflation
and so on but the local level the fight
is between a growth machine and the rest
of us who as neighbors as living in a
neighborhood the growth machine's
tendency is to move out and move into
neighborhoods
either to put in office buildings or to
put in apartment buildings that is say
you're living in this nice wonderful
neighborhood you've bought this house
all people have these you know
single-family dwelling and income the
growth machine because there's more
people now and they can make more money
if they put a big apartment building in
the middle of
little area and you don't like that the
constant sight is between them the
growth machine and neighborhood and that
really animates city politics now this
this conflict can be very liberal or it
can be very reactionary that is that
sometimes neighborhoods are protecting
themselves from toxic waste from
tremendous overcrowding and a liberal
person can certainly understand that and
identify with that kind of with the
neighbors in that conflict but other
times the conflict is such that it's
very reactionary because the neighbors
are trying to keep out minority people
or they are in essence saying we don't
want a more dense zoning because we like
having our two acre and lot but by
having a two acre lot they're making
housing prices more expensive for
everybody in the city so in other words
you can't then find enough land to build
houses for for people of more average
income so what I then saying is that you
have to look at this constant conflict
between the growth machine and
neighborhoods but same time you don't
necessarily say one side is going to be
what we show that the neighborhoods are
going to be progressive now what then
happens in local politics is that some
neighborhood issue will come up that is
in some way the growth machine will
encroach upon a neighborhood they're
going to put a bigger freeway in they're
going to put a high-rise in they're
going to put a factory that belches
smoke into the neighborhood one of those
put a noisy installation in the
neighborhood will be incredibly
galvanized it will fight but once the
fight is over in their neighborhood they
tend to lapse back into their ordinary
routines and of course in terms of
something I said earlier you can now see
my generalization about disruption
people go into action when their
routines are disrupted and if I live in
this nice idyllic neighborhood and now
there's going to be this smelly
smokestack plant or this noisy office
building or a big freeway right near my
house you've disrupted what I see is my
routine existence you see or you've now
overcrowded this school or for some
people you put minority kids in this
school
by building this new neighborhood you've
disrupted what I saw is my way of life
and I become an activist at the
neighborhood level but once my
neighborhood is taken care of I tend to
lapse back into quiet to once again so
in a city at different times we'll see
different neighborhoods in action
meanwhile the structures and
organizations institutions of the local
power structure remain intact and remain
in basic control right and they are
there usually of course rooted in the
chamber of commerce but there's usually
some watchdog tax organization there's
also some real estate association
there's also at the national level
incidentally an organization called the
Urban Land Institute that does the think
tanking for these local growth machines
these local growth machines have
committees of the chamber of commerce
that parallel the government committees
that is for instance for the Planning
Commission there's also a committee of
the Chamber of Commerce that looks at
planning so they have a whole parallel
structure to go alongside the government
and usually what happens then
incidentally is that a person is
legitimated as a city leader by being a
president the chamber by being the head
of its planning committee and then that
person then runs then excuse me that
person then gets appointed to the
Planning Commission then after he or she
has been on the Planning Commission for
a while which then legitimates them as a
city servant they then run for city
government in one city in Northern
California in a larger study that was
done by political scientists of 10 or 15
Bay Area San Francisco Bay Area City
they had the most wonderful process I
mean these people had such a lock on the
whole thing it was outrageous and that
the way it worked was he'd appoint a
person to the Planning Commission Midway
and any of course you had your people on
the City Council
midway through the person on the City
Council's second term it was a two-term
limit in that city midway through the
person's second term they would resign
and a person from the Planning
Commission would be appointed by the
rest of the City Council to the City
Council that person would then two years
later
as an incumbent for the next term and
then of course due his resignation after
he won his second election two years so
so you had a process then that everybody
was running was always an incumbent by
means of appointment but you can see the
process from your local growth machine
member you get involved in the Chamber
committee you get appointed to the
Planning Commission then you run for
City Council that's sort of the ideal
career from the local power Santa Cruz
where you live has a progressive City
Council how are people able to counter
this sort of machine or power structure
politics seemed unable to maintain it or
like they have been and but the
important thing to understand is that
where there have been successful
challenges to the growth machine there
has been very great environmental
concern coupled with usually student
politics that is when the University
California was brought to Santa Cruz by
the growth machine as the perfect
complement to the tourism industry Santa
Cruz is on a wonderful beautiful beach
and its main main things that occur with
machine is tourism which means it
doesn't want any dirty industry spoiling
but the University was a clean industry
high level you know swinging in students
you get that state budget it was a great
poof or that local growth machine to get
UC Santa Cruz okay
and also furthermore the university runs
in the winter and tourism tends to run
in the summer is perfect but the
university was put inside the city
limits for water hookups and other minor
kind of reason but the university is a
giant Trojan horse inside the growth
machine because once this 18-year old
vote was put him the growth machine does
not won a single battle in the Santa
Cruz they wanted to expand northward on
the coast with a big freeway and they
would have taken in huge ranch lands
that would have become 40 50 thousand
people it's all going to be Park they
wanted to expand their amusement area on
a beautiful piece of land it was stopped
by the environmentalists in the city
plus the student vote so I think the
answer in Santa Barbara and Santa
in Davis California with progressive
governments is a student vote but right
over the hill from where I live is Palo
Alto California and in that particular
City
the gravity machine has also been
stopped in good measure but there you
have to understand that the people
stopped but that there was a suburban
town and the people who lived in that
town are well-to-do people and it's
their neighborhood and they're not they
fought off the growth machine in that
town by getting experts to do a study
which showed that the developer land
which was on these foothills that that
Lane that was actually cheaper for the
city to buy that land and put it in
preserve than to pay for all of the
infrastructure that would be needed to
develop that land you see the standard
line of the growth machine is that it's
very good to have development because it
will create more jobs and bring in more
taxes when you do a cost-benefit
analysis it often is the case but not
necessarily always that it costs more to
bring in this new growth to ordinary
citizens then they really do get out of
it
so in some places the growth machine has
been stopped there's also a wonderful a
kind of if I may use the word a
dialectic that goes on between the
growth machine in a neighborhood because
growth machine will create a new
community and they'll build all these
houses and the people will be very happy
and everything's lovely but as you get
more and more people in the city at a
certain point the very city you've
created as a developer rises up and says
you are going to spoil what you
originally promised if you bring more
people and then all the center is a vote
against the developers and they are
stopped so that kind of conflict
happened progressive governments now I
want to say one other thing related to
this growth machine business that's
outside of a city level it shows how how
how different the disruptions can be
Santa Monica California also has a very
progressive government what happened
there was it was a it was a city of
little single dwellings very nice little
city on the coast had some well-to-do
but it was a lot of it was middle-class
a new freeway was developed in the late
60s I believe it was
called the Santa Monica freeway and what
that freeway did was make it possible to
for Santa Monica now to be a bedroom
community for lots more of La which was
a very attractive possibility because of
smog that meant that the land in LA in
Santa Monica was now tremendously more
valuable if you put high-rises on it so
Santa Monica was dramatically
transformed into this community of these
huge apartments now once you have these
people in these apartments then of
course you want to charge a maximum rent
and in the context of the 70s their
rents were going up like crazy and some
of these people retired people and they
were middle little level people what
happened was that some progressive
people moved to that city and they said
the sensible issue to organize this city
around is rent control and they went out
random rent control initiative now the
first time they lost but then something
called proposition 13 happened in
California that controlled property
taxes part of winning that part of the
growth machines in California winning
that Proposition 13 was to promise their
renters that that they wouldn't raise
their rents because now property taxes
would be lower but in fact rents went up
the following year in Santa Monica and
the progressive politicians and went
back at another Grove rent control
initiative and this time they won
overwhelmingly plus their candidates run
for for City Council but the politics of
Santa Monica have to be understood in
terms of of a very dramatically rapidly
changing a situation for the growth
machine in which it had realized
fantastic values thanks to this freeway
put up all these apartment building but
once they started to really raise the
rents on these people the people
rebelled through rent control so rent
control became the device through which
the growth the growth machine is
actually set options now go let cetera
and then we see the power structure
moving in again
with a media blitz and later campaigns
putting a lot of money in getting some
of these progressives out some of the
constant sort of struggle right and in
the case of Santa Monica where I think
the progressive politicians were very
farsighted very clever about this and
understand it had the kind of theory
we're talking about that allowed them to
anticipate they said where are these
these growth machine people going to
strike back at is they said they're
going to strike back on us talk about
crime about more police and so on so the
next program that the progressives
developed was one around a progressive
way of dealing with the question of
crime and and prevention of crime and so
on and in essence what they did was to
take away every issue that the the
growth machine tried to use to beat them
at a certain point what happened in
Santa Monica that again shows this
flexibility is that the developers would
come to them and say okay we want to
develop a certain things what do you
want and they say well we'll let you
build a building here if you put a park
over here if you put childcare over here
and if you put some low-income housing
over here we'll let you develop it so
the big developers would cost it out and
they'd say okay the smaller developers
would say is blackmail it's blackmail
they were all they were angry but you
know what today I just read this the
last month or two in New York time 60 70
percent of American cities are now doing
that very kinds of quote blackmail with
developers they're saying you're going
to develop okay you're going to pay for
the school you're going to pay for the
new roads you're going to put a park
over here you're going to put some
low-income housing over here I wonder if
Austin's doing this yet no no we aren't
that progressed maybe we have a lesson
to learn from now that's the way I mean
the developers will accommodate to that
other see that here's the dynamic of
America the power because of our history
and our ideology the way the economic
system work tremendous amount of power
is lodged than in this these private
economic institutions developers landed
interests at the local level capital big
corporations at the national level the
only thing that other people can do is
to gain some measure of political power
that forces these economic powers to in
some way
accommodate when you have in Santa Cruz
you see where we're progressive and
liberal people have political power what
they use that for is to then make trades
with these businesspeople to to bring
amenities to the cities this recently
the two sides cut a deal in which the
the downtown business community and the
tourism industry agreed to accept with
with no fight at amusement tax but that
amusement tax is going to be used to
fund social services in Santa Cruz that
would probably be lost if these Reagan
cutbacks go through the ones that are
currently being debated in Congress and
certainly we're eliminated Reagan
proposed getting rid of all these
support services so we were able to be
able to get these social kinds of
services and as I say you can allow them
to build certain kinds of things if
they'll do it an environmentally sound
way and if they'll also build other
kinds of thing and so you have this
irony of where we're getting sort of
public amenities but not through
taxation which which are ideology in
America generally is such that it's very
hard then to tax anybody including these
people and to go after traxion taxing
them directly they can often then use
that against you but if you say we'll
let you develop this if you give us the
following amenities it works well bill
you've got a lecture coming up here and
a few minutes at the University of Texas
we want to thank you for it well my
pleasure I rather enjoyed it greatly
it's something a lot and it seems to me
that the basic to a lot of what you were
saying all the way through is that we do
have an American power structure but the
people have to struggle and organize and
demand and put pressure on it
because otherwise we I believe do the
job
Americans are all liberals in a classic
sense whether they think of themselves
as Republicans or Democrats and we have
to constantly build on that liberal
tradition use that liberal tradition and
use it against the the power structure
it's it's it's it's part of our culture
there's a history of activism at various
levels of our country there's America's
basically if I put it this way
closing America is a conservative
country with a liberal ideology in which
at various times we get these chances
and what you have to do is make hay when
those chances come like in the 30s or
we're like in the 60s and I think it
will come around again and then the
trick is to be there basically demanding
as much democracy as much civil liberty
as you possibly can all of which are
perfectly legitimate things to ask for
in the United States of America